que quelques-uns gauthierrybinsky cette
CPE a été pensée par Emmanuel Macron
c'est un format élargi de l'Union
européenne en quelque sorte oui on
pourrait dire un machin de plus une
organisation de plus mais là où c'est
intéressant si vous voulez vous venez de
le dire c'est que ce format réunit des
pays européens qui ne sont pas dans
l'Union européenne et qui pourtant de
par ce qu'ils vivent par les événements
de parler les risques les conflits les
confrontations sont les trois tenants
liés à l'Europe et deuxièmement ça
permet aussi d'avoir une discussion
probablement plus franche que dans le
cadre de l'Union européenne où là vous
savez qu'il y a un côté couperait si
vous tel pays n'est pas d'accord ça veut
dire qu'on bloque les choses alors que
là on peut très bien discuter échanger
des vues essayez même de convaincre le
partenaire ça ne porte pas à conséquent
si on n'est pas d'accord donc c'est
peut-être si vous voulez une instance de
de pas de planification mais pour
aplanir justement certains différents
très politiques oui c'est ce qui manque
parfois l'Union européenne une
communauté qui s'est créée pendant la
guerre en Ukraine et d'ailleurs
l'Ukraine est au cœur des discussions
oui l'Ukraine est au cœur des
discussions parce que c'est évidemment
ça qui qui qui anime non seulement
l'Europe mais le monde entier tellement
tel les répercussions tellement les
répercussions sont grands on l'a vu en
terme alimentaire par exemple mais là ce
qui est important c'est que on dit
l'Union européenne montre une figure
unie fait front face à la Russie en
faveur de l'Ukraine mais on sait très
bien qu'à l'intérieur de ce front il y a
des appréciations très divergentes
d'abord de ce que doit être la guerre en
Ukraine de ce que doit être son issue de
ce que doivent être éventuellement les
négociations et de ce que doivent être
ensuite les garanties ou les protections
qui seront accordées non seulement à
l'Ukraine mais à d'autres États voire la
Moldavie ou se déroule ce sommet dans le
cadre d'un règlement global de cette
affaire et là on sait bien qu'il y a des
embuses qu'il y a encore des divergences
et comme c'est un ce que vous venez de
dire une instance politique on essaie de
chercher le fond de l'histoire le fond
de l'histoire il est bien politique on
l'a dit répéter ici sur ces plateaux
c'est le fait que la dérive du régime
poutinien vers une autocratie vers une
dictature avec tout ce que ça suppose de
mobilisation et d'artefacts pour tromper
la population sur regardez vous venez de
dire une invasion ukrainienne les Russes
une invasion ukrainienne une invasion ça
suppose des milliers d'hommes là je sais
pas il y en a peut-être 100 200 une
invasion avec 100 personnes c'est pas
sérieux bon vous voyez ça c'est de la
propagande etc mais de montrer de
d'avoir un front commun politique et non
plus tactique comme c'est parfois au
sein de l'Union européenne c'est
important je dis pas que cette
communauté réussie à tout mais elle elle
a ce mérite là de poser les problèmes
dans le fond et politique il y a un
autre sujet de tension qui traverse le
continent et c'est l'occasion d'en
reparler à l'occasion de cette CPE c'est
la poussée de fièvre au Kosovo et là
encore les Russes ne sont jamais bien
loin en ville tout à fait alors cette
poussée de fièvre on va pas la
développer bien qu'elle le mériterait ce
qui s'est passé c'est que lors
d'élection municipale la partie serbe du
Kosovo
estimé que les élections étaient
truquées et à boycotter et résultat des
courses et les candidats albanophone se
sont retrouvés en position d'être élus
forcément mais avec des scores de
participation ridicules donc là il y a
effectivement une contestation possible
restons-en là dans l'immédiat simplement
quand vous dites les Russes ne sont
jamais loin c'est qu'il faut pas perdre
de vue que ce qui s'est passé en 1999
c'est à dire l'intervention de l'OTAN au
Kosovo
a été considéré par la Russie qui était
en très délicate position à l'époque
comme une gifle monumentale pourquoi
parce que l'OTAN est intervenu sans
mandat et les Russes considèrent qu'il y
a là la preuve la plus patente des
manipulations de l'Ouest et que
finalement
ils en trouvent une revanche aujourd'hui
dans la conduite de l'invasion en
Ukraine et c'est là qu'il y a une
quelque chose de très spéciaux c'est
qu'en fin de compte l'OTAN est intervenu
bien sûr vous me direz il y a les
intérêts américains bien sûr il y a les
intérêts européens entre nous on
pourrait discuter longtemps des intérêts
qu'on tirés de de faire des Américains
vu l'émergence d'une petite République
du Kosovo mais disons il y a les
intérêts mais en même temps qu'est-ce
que ça a donné comme résultat de sauver
une population albanophone qui était
étripée massacrée et il s'agissait là
peut-être pas d'un génocide parce que on
va pas employer les mêmes termes que
Moscou de façon exagérée mais il
s'agissait d'un être nocif d'éradiquer
la culture albanophone du Kosovo au
profit des herbophones donc c'est
important de rappeler cette matrice
parce que vous voyez qu'au fond la
relativisme des choses telles qu'il est
pratiqué par Moscou et par d'autres qui
consiste à dire oui là il y a eu un
problème donc il est normal qu'on prenne
la revanche mais non il est pas normal
parce que les choses sont radicalement
différentes et que Moscou s'attaque à
une population là aussi pour tenter des
radiquer la culture ukrainienne comme
les Serbes avaient tenté de le faire
avec la culture albanophone et c'est pas
totalement hasard si cerbérus sont
étroitement liés culturellement et
presque affectivement et on voit
derrière vous